du blé de la farine et du pain
c'est l'histoire d'une filière 100% haut
saônoise imaginé par bernard ab le
patron des boulangers du département la
haute-saône ces deux cent cinquante
mille hectares de terres agricoles dont
37 mille consacrée à la culture du blé
quand est née l'idée d'une baguette 100%
de haute saône les céréaliers ont dit
oui
depuis plusieurs années la consommation
de pain en france elle diminue donc si
c'est par ce biais là on peut permettre
aux gens de d'augmenter ou de d'éviter
la diminution la consommation pain c'est
tout bénef pour les producteurs de
grandes cultures que je suis le passe à
un symbole quoi c c'est le symbole de la
france colpin donc c'est faut pas qu'on
se rate sur le pain ne pas se rater et
même faire beaucoup mieux
deux moulins du département produisent
cette farine médine haute saône dont le
moulin faux richert dormoy situe à
fougerolles ici l'entreprise emploie une
vingtaine de salariés et livres presque
200 boulanger du quart nord-est de la
france
le meunier voit dans cette initiative
départementale une opportunité pour son
métier ça nous oblige en fait à
travailler tout simplement sur des
variétés locales de blé et d'essayer de
d'approfondir le la relation dans la
filière avec les agriculteurs pour pour
utiliser des blés de terroir et faire
notre notre réel métier de meunier qui
consiste avant tout à assembler les
variétés de blé pour une farine de
qualité halle saint loup sur semouse
elysées jérôme cap des font partie des
boulangers qui produisent la fameuse ou
saônoise il propose déjà une baguette de
tradition label rouge très exigeante
dans la fabrication alors adopté ce
nouveau pas n'a pas été très compliqué
et là haut saônoise rassure le client
c'est vraiment la provenance d'où ça
vient
il sauf que voilà ça reste dans le coin
donc
donc donc ça va être meilleur quoi on
fait quoi il ya une traçabilité
c'est plus facile d'en discuter parce
qu'ils n'ont pas en discuter avec les
moulins et puis on discutait avec plus
facilement aussi avec le client quoi
donc voilà ça leur parle plus une douce
à bien les circuits courts c'est dans
l'air du temps tout le monde en réclame
dacca voir les magasins de producteurs
qui se montrent elles ça marche
donc il faut suivre un pot offert six
marches c'est notre survie
prochaine étape envisagée un pas 100%
haut saônois et bio la filière
agriculteurs meunier boulanger serait
partante
et là ce serait la cerise sur le gâteau